[Music]
I'm starting to worry that BuzzFeed is
losing steam they're starting to yeah
run low on good ideas for less you'll
see what I mean with this new piece we
call BuzzFeed's running out of lists
[Music]
[Applause]
here are some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently that worried me here's 1/8
maximum security prisoners who send
poems to Zac Efron I bet there's more
than that there's more than that there's
this little this 116 epic Lego fails 9
Bedouin 's you've never heard of what
kind of what kind of list is that I do
not know that guy yeah here's one 25
dogs who think licking themselves is
morally wrong he wants to stop but eat
let him let them here we go 13
Craigslist killers who are wondering
what time you want to come by and see
the futon here we go 42 incredible
photos of Jerry Seinfeld's wait mom
jeans yeah there we go 12 bumpy things
that are swear words in Braille that guy
see you that guy melon is just as this
one say goodbye to these four regional
antacid brands that's they all said a
kusuda oh seven rainy day activities
that involve black tar heroin oh boy
fine you don't know yeah look at this
one eight guys who kind of look like
Jake Gyllenhaal from the back dead
ringer yeah here's one seventeen
tropical drinks that will get you killed
in South Boston do not order that
cocaine I don't here's 121 goldfish who
are sick of their Casa doesn't even want
to go in there eleven origin stories for
the yellow stain your pillow to see the
show is free everyone shut up
I paid nothing a NIDA man who
and then 16 objects Gary Busey is
feuding with here we go here's a good
one 13 ways to make your late husband
notice you and finally danny trejo 10
commandments of clarinet maintenance
[Applause]